good evening and thanks for joining us
tonight at 11 o'clock I'm Sasha Loftis
tonight you may notice a lot of purple
lights across the valley that color
represents National Crime Victims rights
week in addition our local law
enforcement held a ceremony today to
honor not only victims of crime but
those officers who were right there to
pick up the pieces eight news now
reporter Madison Kimbrough joins us live
near the World Market Center tonight
with this story Madison
yeah Sasha as you can see the World
Market Center is lit up in purple right
behind us as for other major spots
across the valley and this afternoon we
were able to talk with local law
enforcement and Advocates who share how
vital it is for victims to have a voice
no do not go and drive that vehicle
you've drank too much a clear message at
the stop DUI Heroes and handcuffs
ceremony it was held at the Henderson
Police headquarters Sunday afternoon
gratitude the ceremony honoring police
officers across Clark County who have
stopped dangerous drivers while out on
our roadways when we talk about impaired
driving a lot of times people Overlook
that they think it's just alcohol but
it's not it's a drug it's the buzz
driving it's things that can impair you
those prescription medicines that can
cause these collisions as well in total
there were 856 DUI arrests in Clark
County in 2022 and currently Metro has
seen 10 DUI fatalities in their
jurisdiction this year Sunday's event
was also to honor DUI victims and family
members like Alma Rodriguez who lost her
husband in an accident due to a drunk
driver isn't that easy when you have
somebody who has been killed by a train
driver so everything is you know it
different after that because you know in
my case my husband we have four children
and they need the father in addition to
the stop DUI Heroes and handcuffs
ceremony it is crimes victims rights
week and Marcy's law named after a woman
who was murdered by her ex-boyfriend in
the 1980s advocates for victims rights
Kim Schofield with Marcy's law for
Nevada explains Marcy's law was actually
voted in by voters in 2018 what it does
is it offers a voice and rights and
information to victims of crime as they
go through the Justice process and Las
Vegas making it known that they stand
with victims by going purple from the
Eiffel Tower at Paris Las Vegas to The
Palms Casino and the High Roller
observation wheel at the link
like the places we mentioned plus so
many more will be lit up throughout the
week National Crime Victims rights week
starts today and will last until
Saturday reporting live Madison
Kimbrough 8 news now now at the heroes
and handcuffs Ceremony this afternoon
Raiders players were ones to present the
stop DOI Awards to those recognized 15
officers were recognized along with
stopped DUI engraved handcuffs with the
names of victims of deadly DUI crashes